[Music]
so
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
standing in london i'm in edgeware right
now and i want to introduce you to a guy
he's called reggie regive when i first
met him he was absolutely skinny he had
nothing he came into this country from
israel with literally no one in his
pocket was working for 40 pounds a day
as a laborer now he's got his own
construction company it's called yoffi
construction he drives a range rover he
lives in a beautiful house so forgive
come on in man show us around your house
great to see you
love you guys your story
you should be he should be the most
famous construction worker in the whole
of london thank you very much so is it
true you came into this country nothing
yes that's true just a little dog
yeah little dog in the 50 pound and
you're working for 40 pounds a day as a
labourer yeah and now you've become a
developer yeah oh man i love it so this
is just one of his projects that we're
going to show you around however we've
just been driving around the whole of
edgeware and regive kept stopping we was
like that's my house that's my house
that's my house i've also here two hmos
but one of them is occupied full
occupied and
second one ever empty too boring he
built an empire thanks god yeah thanks
god yeah
all right so firstly just tell us
something off from the outside so this
property um it's currently just one big
house
at the moment it's a one big house the
split into two flats it's called
masonite right so you're splitting flats
yeah so you're having to get planning
permission of course when you bought it
how did you know that you'd be able to
get planning permission to split it when
you check around the houses around you
can see that many of them are already
split yes um it's kind of like a concept
in this street now you bought the
property for how much i bought it for
570 with stamp duty holiday so it was
close to 600. so 600 all in including
stamp duty
and where did you get the money from
so on this one i didn't have any equity
i already invested on other properties
so
one of my uh partners he always like
asked me what
will be the next deal that we can do so
like it's no problem i already have a
deal but i don't have any equity would
you like to invest it right so you
borrowed the money from a private
investor no i just put him as my partner
he's investing and i'm running the deal
so basically no money down deal
whatsoever for me right so you're going
50 50. 50 50 yeah okay so you you found
the deal where did you find the deal
on zoopla okay founded it on zupla
bought the property all in 600 grand you
found a joint venture partner that put
the money in and now you're turning it
into two flats yes with the help of 150k
show me around the building show me what
you're doing let's say
so here will be one first flip okay so
this is going to lead you to the second
flat upstairs right and then this is
going to be flat number one
okay so this would be like open friendly
kitchen
living room
this is getting more expensive yes
materials become very expensive
everything's getting more expensive it's
very noisy where we're standing right
now i can hear workmen sweeping i can
hear the trains
and weasels
yeah so whereabouts are we exactly the
location is in mill hill it's north
london very known uh
neighborhood in the area
so this is going to be the bedroom yeah
that's going to be the master bedroom
with an ensuite yeah and exit for the
decking in the garden
okay so how long is this entire project
it looks like
it although it looks
very bare
it looks like you've got all the
foundations pretty much ready to go how
how how far through are you through the
project so we are close like i would say
like a month before the end uh electric
all rewired new yeah you're plumbing
showers already
multi finishes you see is already
applied yeah and we are close to
painting on this one upstairs is already
painted as a first coat
and where do you get all this stuff from
like where do you look and start i got
it in
[Music]
you can get it even in weeks i have my
own suppliers everything a better
condition and prices but yeah you can
get it in 17 weeks so this is going to
be then so nice big open plant kitchen
living area good sized bedroom with an
ensuite what's this through here taking
through here so this is all like what
was the side of the house so it used to
be the garage right that's another
bedroom
okay here is going to be the machine
room with the boiler washing machine and
the dryer yes
so extended this thing here yeah we
extend to the side and we extend to the
rear we also extend to the rare on first
floor and to the side on first floor
with the loft so basically this is the
maximum you can push a house with
extensions and the thing is if you go
really far up north sometimes
the amount of money it costs to extend
the house it's not worth it but here in
london every extra inch has so much
exactly what you teach that every penny
you want to spend on the build you want
to get four or five times more back on
the same painting yeah and here it's
really opening that's great so and
you've got another bedroom here as well
yes so
massive apartment yes
yeah it's gonna be like you think uh
with 1100 square foot right
three bedroom flats yeah totally
self-contained but how much on the
refurb you've had to extend you've split
it into two big flats how much in total
is the whole refurb cost
150k one fifth day yeah so 150k and
that's that's not just what you've done
that's everything where it's going to be
finished that's my costume
yeah to build it right so i mean
if you were a developer and you would
call any other contractor it will be way
more expensive sure but you've done it
yourself and you've over you project
managed it
everything i source it i
in this one i didn't find it but
i source it i build it i run it i yeah
so all in you're talking around about
7.50 yes for absolutely everything the
purchase price the refurb the project
management the planning yeah 750 all in
it's about ready show me upstairs and
then i want to know what the gdv is at
the end of it
so what's this is this is the lounge
area yeah that's going to be the kitchen
living room area kitchen will be on this
wall and a little bit up to here right
okay
and a little
nice yeah and again it's noisy because
the windows are open there are no doors
so that's why it's a little bit noisy
it's still a construction site yes
so this is the main bedroom
that's not the main bedroom that's just
a bedroom it's very spacious but the
master bedroom is actually upstairs in
the loft okay so apartment two is over
two floors yes
is this going to be the more expensive
apartment
no because i believe people are
looking for the gardens those days right
okay even though this one will have a
piece of garden but it's not a direct
access right so it will be i believe a
little bit cheaper than the glass has
got island kitchen as well
yeah good but it's nice yes it's very
nice this is the third bedroom it's a
little bit funny but this is what we
could do
more kids bedroom maybe yeah this is
definitely a kid's kid's bedroom it
could be quite nice though but if you
get a cart and a little it could be a
little
area
or i want to see the master bedroom
love it
very spacious
yes private ensuite
massive
whoa
it's almost a bit scary so what's this
going to be what kind of window are you
going to put here it's going to be a
close panel on the bottom and windows on
the top right
function and a lot of lights
so tell me what was the biggest
challenge with this property that this
project what's been the biggest
challenge so far i had a challenge in
here with neighbours okay
um straight when i've done the first
application for extensions yeah i had an
objection from neighbor yeah so it's cut
me off as a corner from the extension
all right
then when i reached the planning to
split the two flats
again i had
um
i had five objections
and in five objections it's
automatically to commit it yeah and that
can take you a few months ahead and
i didn't know what to do
so basically i go i
i sit down to speak with one of the
objections
and i prospered her to to please change
it so she changed it from objections
into actually supporting oh good on top
of that so it's reduced to four on top
of that i go to like few people in the
street
and collect
positive
comments as well
six positive comments i organized
against the four and it passed thanks
guys
yeah so that's a really important lesson
though
actually having relationships in the
neighborhood in the community very
important when you're applying for
planning commission it is yes so tell us
final growth development value so once
it's finished next month what's the
price going to be what's the value going
to be of this whole entire building so
according to the bank that valued our
other flat that it's a few hundred
meters from here yeah the value of each
one of those flats would be at least
600. wow
the total value is 1.2 million 1.2
million pounds that's so good the
investment so you made a profit
you're talking about 450 000
yes but in a flip
but you but but you're going to
refinance it exactly which means you're
not going to pay any tax yeah which
means you're going to be able to pull
out all of your money plus maybe 100k
more oh my goodness how how have you
managed to make this project so
profitable that's incredible i don't
know i mean i'm lucky
i find a little deal i'm searching a lot
i think you're looking because you've
done this again and again and again and
again you've got so many projects yeah
and all of them you're putting all your
money out yes because
when you walk in a small area you
already know the the numbers i mean all
the due diligence is already
there exist
now you just need to find the properties
that match the numbers that you're
looking for so i know how much is my
cost
how much is my purchase price it helps
being a builder
very much did my training help as well
of course that i was a builder before
you yes but since i met you
i
am a property investor right so i'm i'm
doing all those kind of investing in
properties uh going putting offer on the
houses or everything like that i didn't
know what is our why before i met you so
yeah wow man i appreciate that you know
what though if you're going to work hard
anyway you might as well get rich focus
you were working so hard
before you met me before you knew about
property investment as a laborer and now
you've tweaked it and you're not working
as a laborer for other developers you
are the developer
yes and i think making almost half a
million pound on one project one house
is it blows my mind because to think
you've got to make to think
make it half a million pounds you think
you have to build 10 houses or i mean i
made half a million pounds and i've done
or even less on projects way bigger you
know so i'm very impressed with the
margins i guess it helps that you're a
builder
but also it kind of makes me think
i've got a lot of bar refurbishing
finance projects up north
maybe it's better to do them in london
of course you're more than welcome
really good so guys man honestly
maybe you've got deals going on up north
in durham and newcastle liverpool
maybe think about coming to london
because the deals are here you found
this from zoopla yes but we need to
mention that the game in london is a
bigger game
yeah you cannot come with the 30 or 50k
and looking for deals in london it's not
going to happen no but you can come with
nothing yes yes that's true that's true
if you know the skills to raise finance
yes
or bring a big
value with you yes
the love of it love it
man so proud of you man
i'm definitely going to be coming back
to this house when you've completely
finished it of course but so so so good
and you know what guys if you're
watching this video i just want to say
big up to regieve did a fantastic job
this is not just one of his projects
he's got loads of projects going on
around here you've become the king of
property investment in london oh man
thank you so much please thank you so
much maybe the prince you are the king
oh wow i don't know about that i don't
know about that um
you've gone through the training you've
gone to the discovery day samuel 365.
what should your experience been like
amazing i mean i couldn't leave the
computer when i take a mission on myself
as i told you my name is rig of massive
action falca yeah i didn't leave it i
was like two or three months closed with
you and my computer in the room yeah and
study and
that's it when i finish my studying i go
out from home and i start to put offers
on properties simple as that
just
taking action because i think as well
you know i think it's really important
that before you start buying houses and
investing in property i think you'd
invest a little bit in yourself first
which is what you did yes and anybody
that wants to do the same training
regive did it's 95 pounds a month
correct yes 95 pounds a month you can
have unlimited mentoring all of the
courses at the time i wanted to come to
the crash course but because of the
covey it was all closed shut down so you
did it online online but the crash
course is now open so get booked on get
doing the same thing subscribe to the
channel i'll even give details as well
in the description so connect with him
and guys i'll see you next time
boom
[Laughter]
awesome man